North Korea is officially the most corrupt
country in the World.
The Corruption Perceptions Index ranks every
country in the world from 0 to 100, based
on how corrupt it is, with a score of 0 being
very corrupt and 100 meaning very clean.
Every year North Korea ties with Somalia for
last place.
Let's uncover the most disturbing facts about
the World's favourite hermit kingdom.
North Korea, or more officially known as the
Democratic Peoples Republic of Korea, has
the fourth largest army in the world, with
1.2 million active members, not far behind
America with it's military of 1.4 million.
There are 28 state approved haircuts in North
Korea.
Women are allowed to choose from one of 18
styles.
Married women are instructed to choose shorter
styles, whilst single ladies are permitted
to let loose with a longer style.
Men on the other hand are allowed to choose
from 10 state approved hair cuts, all of which
are short.
All North Korean men are prohibited from growing
their hair longer than 5 centimetres.
North Korea has an impressive 100% literacy
rate.
Literacy is defined as individuals aged 15
and over who can read and write.
There are 25,554 kilometres of roads in North
Korea, but only 724 km are paved, that's a
measly 2.83%.
The Korean Demilitarised Zone, or DMZ.
Is a strip of land 250 kilometres long that
separates South Korea from North Korea.
It was setup as a neutral zone where the two
countries can safely discuss matters, at the
end of Korean War in 1953.
Despite its name, it is the most heavily militarised
border in the world.
Soldiers guarding the DMZ are ordered to shoot
anyone trying to sneak in our out of the country.
Making China the most popular escape route
for North Koreans.
80% of defectors are women.
But an unlikely good has come out of such
a heavily militarised border, the Korean DMZ
strip is home to some of the most critically
endangered species of animals and plants on
Earth.
Whom have found an unlikely haven, protected
from any human contact.
Extremely rare species such as the Korean
Tiger, the elusive Amur leopard and Asiatic
black bear have all found a home here amongst
the landmines and listening posts.
Ecologists have identified some 2,900 plant
species, 70 types of mammals and 320 kinds
of birds within this narrow strip of land.
The South Korea government has campaigned
to UNESCO numerous times to turn the DMZ into
a nature reserve to protect the endangered
animals, but every time North Korea has declined
to make such an agreement.
In the 50s, North Korea built Kijong-Dong
on North Korea's side of the DMZ, so it was
easily visible from South Korea.
Which North Korea claimed was the perfect
city, the city supposedly contained a childcare
centre, kindergarten, primary and secondary
schools, and a hospital.
The idea was to make the city appear so attractive
that it enticed South Koreans to defect to
North Korea.
However, after observation from the South
Korean side of the DMZ, it became obvious
that the city is actually completely uninhabited,
and has remained so ever since it was built.
It has since come to be known as 'Propaganda
Village'.
In the 1980s the South Korean government built
a 98 metre tall flagpole on the south side
of the DMZ, close to the border.
The North Korean government responded by building
an ever taller one in Kijong-Dong, in what
some have called the "flagpole war".
At the time it was the second tallest flagpole
in the world.
In the last 60 years, over 23,000 North Koreans
have defected to South Korea.
Whereas only two South Koreans have gone north
of the border.
North Korea has its own operating system called
Red Star OS, a fork of linux.
Most of the software on there, such as the
web browser, text editor and firewall are
custom programs written by North Korea.
In 1974, Kim Il-Sung took 1,000 Volvo sedans
from Sweden to North Korea and never paid
for them.
In 2013 current North Korean leader Kim Jong-Un
executed his uncle along with five of his
aides by locking them in a cage and feeding
them to a starving pack of 120 dogs.
But what had Kim's uncle done to deserve such
a horrific demise?
Kim accused his uncle of mismanaging the economy,
corruption, womanising and taking drugs.
Marijuana is completely legal in North Korea
and is not even classified as a drug.
It is commonly used for medicinal purposes.
North Korea is the only nation on Earth to
currently have a US Navy ship captured.
It isn't 2015 in North Korea, it is the year
104.
Counted after the birth of Kim Jong Un's grandfather,
and founder of the DPRK, Kim Il-Sung.
North Korea is home to the world's largest
stadium.
The impressive May Day Stadium seats 150,000
people.
It is home to the annual Arirang games, which
is one of the most spectacular displays of
coordination and choreography on Earth.
The Ryugyong Hotel in North Korea is a 105
story building that for 20 years held the
title of the world's tallest hotel.
Construction began in 1987, but was halted
before it was finished in 1992, as North Korea
entered a period of economic crisis following
the fall of the Soviet Union.
The monstrosity now towers over Pyongyang
and stands completely empty.
The only people allowed to own vehicles in
North Korea are the military and government
officials.
Transport in general is tightly controlled,
North Korean citizens are generally restricted
from travelling anywhere at all, even inside
their own country.
North Korea's space agency is called "NADA",
which in Spanish means "nothing".
It stands for National Aerospace Development
Administration.
The program only has a 20% success rate.
Wearing jeans is illegal in North Korea because
denim symbolises the DPRK's enemy, the United
States.
Every 5 years North Korea holds a general
election, in which the ballots paper lists
only one candidate.
In 2012 North Korea officially announced that
it had discovered a unicorn lair.
The DPRK's official news agency released a
statement claiming they had found a cave 200
metres from Pyongyang City, with a rectangular
rock in front of it with the words "Unicorn
Lair" conveniently carved into it.
They believe the unicorn was rode by an ancient
Korean king named King Tongmyong.
North Korea is dotted with prison labor camps.
Where prisoners are reportedly subjected to
horrific inhumane treatment.
Prisoners of these concentration camps suffer
a level of slavery, torture and experimentation
comparable with the holocaust.
Although North Korea denies the existence
of such camps, insider sources claim there
are 16 such camps, home to 200,000 prisoners.
North Korea also has a three generations of
punishment law.
This means that anyone sent to a prison camp
is sent along with their entire family, regardless
if they were involved in the crime or not.
Also any family members born whilst in prison
will live their entire lives there, as well
as any children they may have whilst in prison.
North Koreans are subject to a six day work
week, as well as a seventh day of supposed
"volunteer" work, which is also strictly enforced.
Meaning North Koreans have virtually no free
time.
Official records show that Kim Jong il learnt
to walk at the age of three weeks, and was
talking at eight weeks.
Whilst studying at Kim il Sung university,
he reportedly wrote 1,500 books over a period
of three years, along with six full operas.
According to his official biography, all of
his operas are "better than any in the history
of music."
It is also written in Kim Jong il's biography
that he was born under a double rainbow, and
to mark his birth there was a new star and
a swallow in the sky.
It is also written that he could control the
weather and make it rain on command, depending
on his mood.
In fact, the list of questionable claims and
feats of prowess surrounding the former North
Korean leader are endless.
School children are required to learn everything
about their current leader as well as his
two predecessors.
Even if the so called facts may be a bit on
the fabricated side.